[Music]
welcome back to CBS morning's tomorrow
morning Britain's Charles III will
officially be crowned King I'll bet you
thought he was already King but it's
official tomorrow in a coronation
ceremony with historical roots that go
back more than one thousand years wow
now to the new king it may seem as
though he's been waiting almost that
long to take the throne and it hasn't
been easy for him his friends say Holly
Williams is outside Westminster Abbey
with a look back at the 74 year old
King's early life and the troubles he's
had to overcome
Holly good morning big big big day for
him tomorrow
good morning Gail yeah King Charles
waited 70 years to ascend the throne and
fulfill his Destiny tomorrow the crown
of Saint Edward which dates back to the
1600s will finally be lowered onto his
head right behind me here inside
Westminster Abbey now Charles has faced
many difficulties including his troubled
marriage to Princess Diana and
relationship with his son Prince Harry
but one of his biggest challenges may
have been his childhood
birth was announced with a royal gun
salute
[Music]
unto us a child is born and no ordinary
child a prince he was easily the most
famous baby in the world this tiny
sneezing Prince stands next in line of
succession after his mother
at the age of three when his mother
became Queen Charles became the heir to
the British throne
and that was his job for the next seven
decades
he was always just a little bit of an
outsider to start with Johnny stonebra
was a class mate of King Charles then
Prince Charles at gordonston School
in Scotland an institution so tough
Charles has compared it to a prison camp
stormbre says the prince was far from
popular during his school days I would
have thought the the heir to the British
throne would have lots of friends nobody
wanted to be his friend because if you
were his friend you were then teased
brutally for being his friend in fact
stonebra says Charles was lonely shy and
badly bullied we were playing rugby
football and a couple of the boys
decided that they were going to quite do
the prince which means beat him up you
know pull his ears punch him and he
never complied he never said a word and
if I hadn't have actually seen it nobody
would know about it going home from his
boarding school may not have been much
comfort now swing High swing low for the
Young Prince the late Queen has been
described as a distant mother Prince
Philip a harsh father Prince Charles
Future King of England comes a college
freshman and compounding Charles's
problems was the media
spent his entire youth under scrutiny
well wish you shouted good luck and the
prince replied I'll need it
in an interview with an adult with
Britain's ITV he revealed just how much
he hated it
I'm not very good at being a performing
monkey really
and I I think that I'm quite as a dude
private person I I'm not prepared to to
just perform Johnny stonebrough believes
King Charles was left scarred by his
school days and his bullies and told us
being royalty is like serving a prison
sentence I have to do have to ask myself
sometimes whether being
a member of the royal family isn't
actually far more of a curse than a
pleasure I think it's a real burden and
I'm always so impressed by the people
who can manage it
according to the polls King Charles is
significantly less popular than both his
mother the late Queen and his son Prince
William but the monarchy as an
institution still has overwhelming
support in this country and tomorrow
Royal fans will be out in force here in
central London back to you guys in New
York yeah but you got a feel for him
when you look at his childhood I mean
children can be so mean I'm excited for
him I'm excited for him as well but you
got a feel for him with the weather as
well Holly you're shouting over the rain
there Holly it sounds like a train
behind you is it going to rain tomorrow
too I don't know what the forecast is
right now we've got thunder lightning
and what feels like torrential rain
let's hope it brightens up for tomorrow
I hope so too let it let it rain today
so it'll be sunny skies tomorrow but
that does not look good the divine right
of kings not more powerful than the
weather Holly thank you very much I'd
like the king's mustache in the 70s as
well that was nice to see